you cannot change uh the way our we
can't change the way our leaders lead
like i wish we could you know no number
of anonymously sent books
will suddenly change the way that they
lead um
uh if we can keep trying but it won't
work um
um uh we have to be the leaders we wish
we had and so
we can't change the way somebody three
four five levels above us is leading the
company
but we can take responsibility for how
the people to the left of us and how the
people to the right of us
feel when they come to work and by the
way the person who we work for
our boss they're a human being too and
though they may be difficult or
sometimes maybe they're an [ __ ]
do we really know why are they just a
genetic [ __ ]
they may be it absolutely is a
possibility
or maybe they're under extreme stress
that we don't know about
or maybe their bus is an extreme [ __ ]
and just filters down
or maybe they were never taught how to
lead and they're just trying to make the
best of it and they're lying hiding and
faking every day
but there's so many reasons and so
sometimes going into our boss's office
and saying hey you were really you're
really tough of a tough on us
in the meeting today i just wanna make
sure you're okay are you okay
i'm worried about you like we've all
been going through a lot during this
coveted time for example
and so have you um so
being a leader doesn't just mean being a
leader to the people on our level it
means being a leader to the people
around us
and so the way we lead from the bottom
of the totem pole is the exact same
way we lead from every level of the
totem pole which is
uh we take care of those around us um
and we'd be the leaders we wish we had
that is
leadership has nothing to do with rank
it has nothing to do with where we sit
on the totem pole
it's how we take care of those around us
remember leadership is the awesome
responsibility
to see those around us rise
[Music]